Caption: good friend of mine and also one of the
Caption: driving forces behind DD Perth
Caption: conference itself and last year Ashley
Caption: gave us a wonderful gentle introduction
Caption: to functional programming so he's back
Caption: this year again promising an equally
Caption: gentle B code to us
Caption: introduction to quantum computing please
Caption: welcome Ashley okay hello everyone thank
Caption: you for coming along quantum computing
Caption: is a very interesting topic and I think
Caption: really significant so I think you've
Caption: chose the right talk to come along too
Caption: it's gonna be a general introduction in
Caption: the way I ride on the space shuttle is
Caption: gentle at least a take off it's going to
Caption: be a bit fast and furious is a lot to
Caption: get through but hopefully if you can
Caption: keep up with me most of the way and
Caption: follow most of what I say I think you'll
Caption: learn something and see how amazing this
Caption: quantum computing is so the first thing
Caption: here to talk about is get some history
Caption: way back in the days in computing we
Caption: started off with analog computing maybe
Caption: some of you remember the old slide rule
Caption: here and the idea here is you use a
Caption: property of classical world like the
Caption: length of a ruler to calculate
Caption: logarithms and on the right hand side
Caption: here we had a analog computer for
Caption: calculating Exponential's you made up
Caption: specular circuits and the voltage in
Caption: that circuit due to the capacitors and
Caption: resistors would show an exponential sign
Caption: so you could use it put in one voltage
Caption: and calculate an exponential so we had
Caption: these things called analog computers
Caption: based upon classical physics and these
Caption: were great but of course Along Came our
Caption: digital computers classical digital
Caption: computers and these were fantastic these
Caption: are based upon classical physics
Caption: although they use semiconductors to
Caption: implement them and in fact a part of
Caption: classical computers they try to abstract
Caption: away from the physics like a 1 and a 0
Caption: or a true and a false doesn't matter
Caption: whether it's 0.9 volts or 1.1 volts it's
Caption: a 1 doesn't matter whether it's 0.05 or
Caption: 0.1 volts it's a zero so they're trying
Caption: to abstract away from the physics to do
Caption: classical digital computing and we know
Caption: about classical digit computing it's all
Caption: about ands and ORS and nots and pulling
Caption: them all together to process the bits
Caption: well there's something new on the block
Caption: it's called quantum computing and it's
Caption: crazy it's the next revolution in
Caption: computing and I don't say that lightly
Caption: it's gonna be really big and I want to
Caption: try and explain it to you today it's
Caption: based on the quantum world not on the
Caption: classical physics quantum physics but I
Caption: have to be careful here because the
Caption: quantum world is quite bizarre and so
Caption: you may find your head exploding so I
Caption: can't guarantee you anything I will
Caption: promise you you know you may not explode
Caption: in fact here the exploding syndrome is a
Caption: real thing but hopefully we'll get
Caption: through it without your head exploding
Caption: we'll see how we go so a couple of
Caption: things to talk about introduction here
Caption: this is what I want to talk about today
Caption: I want to give you an overview and
Caption: introduce our done that I want to give
Caption: you quantum mechanics some basics to
Caption: help you understand things because the
Caption: quantum world is really different than
Caption: the classical world talk about how we do
Caption: computing in the quantum world talk
Caption: about quantum computers what do they
Caption: look like will they be made of and see
Caption: some applications where they become
Caption: really useful and we're starting to see
Caption: something along those lines already and
Caption: we'll wind up and talk about of the
Caption: future so other points just about myself
Caption: here too I have a background in academia
Caption: in physics computer science AI and IT
Caption: but I also like to work in industry
Caption: consulting and professional training
Caption: I've done jobs around Australia across
Caption: Southeast Asia in the US and the UK for
Caption: companies like Apple and IBM and the
Caption: Commonwealth Bank the last 10 or 15
Caption: years I've been focusing on innovation
Caption: working a lot with startups myself had
Caption: done some accelerators and now I mentor
Caption: and coaching accelerators I focus on the
Caption: Lean Startup approach with customer
Caption: development and I run the lean startup
Caption: Perth meetup if you're interested in in
Caption: doing startups my ventures myself I've
Caption: been involved with three major one my
Caption: current one is innovate Li which
Caption: basically provides consulting services
Caption: around this lean startup with customer
Caption: development innovation also I had a
Caption: software development company and I
Caption: focused on event-driven micro services
Caption: and CQRS I've spoken about that
Caption: previously at this conference and cloud
Caption: and I have a startup on my own which is
Caption: in higher education space try to change
Caption: the way higher education works
Caption: it's called eco Vista but it's are still
Caption: very early stage
Caption: so enough about me let's thank our
Caption: sponsors here our amazing sponsors of
Caption: course we couldn't do this conference
Caption: with our sponsors they're the ones who
Caption: provide all the money to let you guys
Caption: come along and it's great to see met so
Caption: many local companies here supporting the
Caption: conference it's wonderful a wide array
Caption: of sponsors there so thanks to them
Caption: alright so we jump on this so we're
Caption: gonna start now we're gonna go down and
Caption: the Allison Wonder and wishing we all
Caption: sort of thing and hopefully we'll be
Caption: okay
Caption: but stick with me we're going to talk
Caption: now about quantum mechanics or quantum
Caption: physics who did some quantum physics in
Caption: their high school or university a few
Caption: people that's good for the others who
Caption: might seem quite strange but just try
Caption: and follow the reason that does seem a
Caption: bit strange is that we all live in the
Caption: classical world we live in their world
Caption: of you know our meters and kilometers
Caption: and normal gravity and so forth and big
Caption: massive objects like ourselves do you
Caption: throw a ball and it goes straight and it
Caption: drops to the growth from the gravity and
Caption: so forth this is the world we live in
Caption: the classical world this is the way we
Caption: understand things but quantum mechanics
Caption: is very different it's about the
Caption: microscopic or the atomic size world and
Caption: there's no reason there has to behave
Caption: the same as our world and we'll see in
Caption: fact it does behave very differently so
Caption: this is a quantum physics and the first
Caption: experiment which demonstrated quantum
Caption: physics basically there was an electron
Caption: gun and it would fire electron guns a
Caption: little wall there which had two slits in
Caption: it then we have a sensor on the side of
Caption: the wall and of course when you fire
Caption: some of the electrons some went through
Caption: the holes and made a mark on the sensor
Caption: and some of them bounced off the wall
Caption: and didn't go through the holes so what
Caption: people expected was if you look did this
Caption: experiment with single electrons after
Caption: why you'd get a pattern like this to
Caption: areas where the electrons were all going
Caption: through but that was surprised when they
Caption: did this experiment that what they
Caption: actually saw was something very
Caption: different it was like this and this is
Caption: basically a classic thing we see a lot
Caption: of times it's an interference pattern
Caption: made by waves the troughs and then there
Caption: the peaks of the waves where
Caption: get cancellation and superposition of
Caption: the values so this was a strong theme to
Caption: indicate that these electrons weren't
Caption: behaving like particles and just going
Caption: through the slits but in fact they were
Caption: behaving like waves so the electron wave
Caption: came here to separate parts went through
Caption: the actual slits and then those two
Caption: separate waves were interfering and
Caption: causing the pattern but remember the
Caption: pattern over there isn't like some
Caption: painting on the wall is statistically
Caption: where the particles will go it's a
Caption: probability distribution so these waves
Caption: aren't like water waves or air waves
Caption: they're wave describing the distribution
Caption: of probabilities associated with this
Caption: electron now this is quite amazing to
Caption: think that electron is behaving like a
Caption: wave and this was the start of quantum
Caption: physics the things we learned from this
Caption: was the electron goes through both slits
Caption: at the same time
Caption: that's pretty freakish we don't see that
Caption: in the real world and the electrons are
Caption: both particles and waves again that's a
Caption: bit strange we see ways and we see
Caption: particles we don't see both things and
Caption: all the people say that can't be true
Caption: you know something's wrong maybe there's
Caption: two electrons are doing things but
Caption: remember is sending one electron through
Caption: at a time it's not going through
Caption: interfering with other electrons it's
Caption: one at a time so people said oh yeah
Caption: what happens if we get a detector there
Caption: and we do try and detect the electron
Caption: which one it's really going through but
Caption: luckily all it's strange that they found
Caption: that when they did that they put a
Caption: detector there they actually detected
Caption: the electron suddenly that pattern
Caption: changed back to this one and why is that
Caption: happened well you have these waves this
Caption: probability wave but when the electron
Caption: interacts with the detector or a
Caption: macroscopic system a big system it
Caption: actually collapses into the one of the
Caption: classical things becomes more like a
Caption: classical electron like a particle so
Caption: when you put the detector there it
Caption: behaves like a particle when you take
Caption: the detector away it behaves like a wave
Caption: strange things this is quantum physics
Caption: so the point here is in quantum physics
Caption: we have a concept of coherence and decay
Caption: and decoherence coherence happens when
Caption: the electrons on its own and not
Caption: interacting with the environment so it's
Caption: doing all the wavy type stuff
Caption: decoherence is when it interacts with
Caption: the environment and the wavefunction
Caption: collapses and it now works like a bahut
Caption: particle that's wavefunction collapse so
Caption: when it's fully isolated the electron
Caption: behaves like a wave it's said to be in a
Caption: coherent quantum wave state when it
Caption: actually interacts with the
Caption: macro-environment then it collapses and
Caption: becomes a classical state so this is the
Caption: details of Cuauhtemoc actually to worry
Caption: about these equations which is a
Caption: Schrodinger equation these are the guys
Caption: who invented quantum mechanics nearly a
Caption: hundred years ago now and the solution
Caption: of this equation is that wave that
Caption: probability wave I was talking about
Caption: which describes where the electrons will
Caption: go with what probabilities that's very
Caption: important quantum physics isn't
Caption: deterministic like classical physics
Caption: it's probabilistic and that's a very
Caption: different so let's explain this look and
Caption: look at two or three of these concepts
Caption: the first one is quantum superposition
Caption: so here we have an electron and this
Caption: electron has a charge and has a spin and
Caption: it causes the magnetic field and that
Caption: magnetic field can be up or down so we
Caption: can say these electron can be in two
Caption: states the up state or the down state it
Caption: can't be halfway it's either up or down
Caption: and we can actually see this is not two
Caption: different electrons this is one electron
Caption: in both the up and the down state at the
Caption: same time
Caption: that's what superposition means you're
Caption: in both states at the same time like the
Caption: electron was going through both switz at
Caption: the same time so don't think it's
Caption: separate the way we described this wave
Caption: function here is we say it's combined of
Caption: some of the uppers and some of the
Caption: Downers and this weight here is used to
Caption: calculate the probabilities that you
Caption: when you measure this electron would you
Caption: find it in the Upstate or would you find
Caption: it in the downstate and this one here is
Caption: balanced so it's 1/2 1/2 if you measure
Caption: it you'd see half the time it's up and
Caption: half the time is down but of course
Caption: again it's just one electron in both
Caption: those states at the same time now that
Caption: it has to be equal these electrons have
Caption: different this electron has different
Caption: weightings so it's more likely to be in
Caption: the up state than in the down state so
Caption: when
Caption: you measure it you're more likely to get
Caption: up then you would get down so there's a
Caption: famous experiment you may have heard of
Caption: Schrodinger's cat where Schrodinger's
Caption: said this is absurd you can't be in both
Caption: states at once if we put a cat inside a
Caption: box and we had a radioactive particle
Caption: here if that radioactive particle
Caption: decayed it would cause the hammer to
Caption: crash the bottle of cyanide here and
Caption: kill the cat if it didn't decay then it
Caption: wouldn't kill the cat and Schrodinger
Caption: said well it's absurd so you're saying
Caption: to me when I can't see inside this box
Caption: the cat is both dead and alive can't be
Caption: that's ridiculous and in fact it is
Caption: pretty ridiculous if you learned high
Caption: school quantum physics or university
Caption: they probably told you that until you
Caption: observed that cat it is either in 100
Caption: other states but our current
Caption: understanding of quantum physics is that
Caption: when that charge when that lect
Caption: radioactive particle interacts with the
Caption: macroscopic system the hammer or the
Caption: device here then actually will collapse
Caption: into one of the states so the cat will
Caption: actually be dead or alive in this
Caption: circumstance macro systems don't operate
Caption: like quantum systems only the particle
Caption: inside here operates like a quantum
Caption: system and that's important too okay
Caption: separate thing to look at here is called
Caption: quantum entanglement and we'll talk
Caption: about this later on - it's important for
Caption: quantum computing think now we have two
Caption: electrons here both of them can be in
Caption: the up or the down state if we made them
Caption: in a way that they had a wavefunction
Caption: which only contains two possible States
Caption: both down and both up and we can
Caption: construct these electrons into this
Caption: particular wavefunction
Caption: alright so it's this much both down and
Caption: this much both up or the other way
Caption: around now what would happen if we
Caption: separate these and we do a measurement
Caption: we interact with this one to find out
Caption: whether it's up or down if we found out
Caption: this one was down what do you think this
Caption: one has to be any ideas no because the
Caption: state here is down down or
Caption: but if this one is down it has to be in
Caption: the down state if we measure this one
Caption: and it's up because the wavefunction
Caption: says it's only split between these two
Caption: things the other one has to be up so
Caption: there's a correlation between the states
Caption: because these two electrons are quantum
Caption: entangled their wave functions are
Caption: depended upon each other this is pretty
Caption: strange they're joined together some way
Caption: and people didn't believe this for a
Caption: long time until they did experiments
Caption: inside the laboratory and proved this
Caption: actually happens it's even quite
Caption: freakier because you can take an
Caption: electron on earth and the Chinese have
Caption: done this and take that electron it
Caption: tangle with Undine here and put one on a
Caption: satellite when you measure the electron
Caption: down here to find out is it up or down
Caption: suddenly the one up here is up or down -
Caption: they're correlated and in fact this is
Caption: actually instantaneous there's no
Caption: information taking time to travel
Caption: between these two they're connected no
Caption: matter how far away they are now for us
Caption: who live on the world on the ground here
Caption: that seems pretty stupid because we are
Caption: used to things that interact with each
Caption: other infecting each other you know
Caption: influence cause-and-effect but here's
Caption: something way away is getting affected
Caption: by something way down here
Caption: quantum entanglement and this is proven
Caption: they've done it on the the satellites
Caption: and it basically showed that they were
Caption: entangled so two things they were seen
Caption: Einstein called this the spooky action
Caption: at a distance and it is pretty spooky
Caption: that it actually happens it's real it's
Caption: the quantum world now a famous physicist
Caption: here Roger Penrose he said quantum
Caption: mechanics makes absolutely no sense so
Caption: if you don't understand this stuff
Caption: you're in good hands this guy had
Caption: quantum physicists he says it doesn't
Caption: make some sense either and the way the
Caption: reason it doesn't make sense is you
Caption: can't think of it understand it in terms
Caption: of our everyday physics our classical
Caption: physics it's what happens in the quantum
Caption: world famous physicist Richard Feynman
Caption: he said if you think you understand
Caption: quantum mechanics
Caption: you don't understand quantum mechanics
Caption: it's that complex and strange right and
Caption: he actually when he said this a year
Caption: later he went on to win the Nobel Prize
Caption: for
Caption: research in quantum physics so he knows
Caption: what he's talking about right so it's
Caption: hard to understand don't be worried and
Caption: you may think well maybe it works like
Caption: that but maybe we just examine a bit
Caption: more it'll work more like the classical
Caption: world but no this is how the world works
Caption: at the quantum scale quantum physics is
Caption: the most accurate and the most tested
Caption: theory in the history of science
Caption: it's amazing quantum physics predicts
Caption: certain values of physical constants and
Caption: when you go and measure them in the real
Caption: world they're precise 211 212 413
Caption: decimal places precision plus or minus
Caption: 28 at the end we don't have here any
Caption: other theories that are that accurate so
Caption: a lot of other quantum physicists when
Caption: people start philosophizing about is the
Caption: world really like this they just say
Caption: sharp and calculate because it gives you
Caption: the right answers right this is what our
Caption: classical computers are based on this is
Caption: what most of modern technology is based
Caption: on it just works quantum mechanics is
Caption: the reality at the quantum level so
Caption: that's pretty strange stuff and you may
Caption: be having an exploiting head at the
Caption: moment bit hard to understand that but
Caption: just think about it we have superstition
Caption: of states and we have entanglement we're
Caption: going to try and build some computers
Caption: based upon these two physical properties
Caption: so quantum computing what's that about
Caption: well as I mentioned classical computers
Caption: focus on building systems based upon
Caption: classical physics or abstracting away
Caption: from the quantum physics getting rid of
Caption: the noise and hiding that stuff you know
Caption: now we have a lot of problems with
Caption: classical computers because we're
Caption: getting down to the level where these
Caption: quantum effects start to happen we don't
Caption: want that happen so we're limited we try
Caption: and stay classical but we want to try
Caption: and build computers which benefit from
Caption: these quantum physics and when we're
Caption: talking about quantum computers we don't
Caption: talk about normal bits we talk about
Caption: quantum bits or they're often called
Caption: qubits for short and these are a core
Caption: part of the quantum computing approach
Caption: so let's try and compare classical bits
Caption: with quantum bits so here we have a one
Caption: classical bit as you know it
Caption: be a 0 or a 1 there are two states and
Caption: it can be in one of those states at a
Caption: time it's either zero or it's one
Caption: quantum beats as we know are different
Caption: this is that quantum superposition a
Caption: quantum bit can be in both the state
Caption: zero and one at the same time now it's
Caption: not 0.5 or 0.6 it's the two states but
Caption: it's a mixture of those states at the
Caption: same time right radical if we keep on
Caption: doing this of course in classical
Caption: computers we have two bits we have four
Caption: states that we're still in one of those
Caption: four states quantum computers that we
Caption: have two qubits we have four states but
Caption: we're in all of those four states at
Caption: once if we decide to be in all of those
Caption: four states and we can keep on going
Caption: three bits eight states in one of those
Caption: states the quantum one three bits in
Caption: eight states at the same time now it
Caption: gets interesting
Caption: think about n bits n classical bits 16
Caption: 32 a hundred you can have lots of
Caption: possible states but you're still only in
Caption: one of those states at a particular time
Caption: this is where it gets interesting for a
Caption: quantum system if you have n bits you're
Caption: in 2 to the N States at the same time
Caption: and there's a distribution about how
Caption: much of each state you're in
Caption: maybe this state or in some more in this
Caption: state or in less and this state you're
Caption: in more quantum states quantum bits are
Caption: very different to show you how this is
Caption: important think about 300 quantum bits
Caption: not too big a number 300 if you had 300
Caption: quantum bits then you have 2 to the 300
Caption: states that you're in and that's more
Caption: States than there are atoms in the
Caption: universe so a lot of states in 300
Caption: quantum bits and if we can use that for
Caption: doing some sort of processing we can do
Caption: amazing stuff so the approaches to
Caption: quantum computing there's two approaches
Caption: we're pretty early stage till what I
Caption: call classical I'm sorry digital quantum
Caption: computing it's analogous to the digital
Caption: classical computing and what I called
Caption: analog quantum computing it's analogous
Caption: to the
Caption: analogue classical computing and this
Caption: approach the first one will focus on
Caption: mostly and it's similar to the
Caption: traditional approach we process these
Caption: bits but in different ways the second
Caption: approach we use the analog computer to
Caption: simulate quantum systems who it turns
Caption: out simulating quantum system is
Caption: actually quite hard to do on a classical
Caption: computer we want to do that to
Caption: understand quantum world so let's have a
Caption: look at the gates or the processes or
Caption: the operations we have in a quantum
Caption: system these gates like we have logic
Caption: gates in a classical system these apply
Caption: to the qubits so we apply an operation
Caption: to the qubit so we have gates like the X
Caption: gate which is similar to a knot we have
Caption: Toffoli gate like an end we have a
Caption: number of different operations here that
Caption: it can apply to one or more of these
Caption: quantum bits it actually turns out that
Caption: these three operations here equivalent
Caption: to classical computing they make the
Caption: quantum computing a universal computer
Caption: just like a classical computer so
Caption: anything we can do in a quantum in a
Caption: classical computer we can do in a
Caption: quantum computer but we probably won't
Caption: want to you will probably focus on the
Caption: things that does differently we're going
Caption: to the details of these but they're just
Caption: different operations apply to these
Caption: quantum bits which are in many states
Caption: well what about the processing in a
Caption: quantum computer what does it progress
Caption: like well we have this dry diagram here
Caption: which explains things these are our
Caption: quantum bits down here and across here
Caption: we can see we're applying different
Caption: operations we apply the H or Hadamard
Caption: operation here then weep reply this
Caption: operation here between these two bits
Caption: another operation here and then this one
Caption: in this one shows here we're measuring
Caption: the quantum bits we're interacting with
Caption: them to find out what their state is
Caption: that causes some quantum wavefunction
Caption: collapse but we can keep on going
Caption: because not all the system is collapsed
Caption: so this is how we describe processing in
Caption: a quantum computer but be careful here
Caption: don't think this is like the electrons
Caption: are flowing through here and these are
Caption: gates the quantum bits actually stay
Caption: where they are we just apply these
Caption: operations to them so this diagram is
Caption: really showing you what happens over
Caption: time to these quantum bits
Caption: do these first we do these and we do
Caption: these and so on so this is the
Caption: processing we do two quantum bits
Caption: there's some problems with quantum
Caption: computers they tend to these bits these
Caption: quantum bits tend to decohere over time
Caption: they lose their coherence they're
Caption: quantumness and I become more classical
Caption: and this introduces Aaron's high error
Caption: rates as a lieu they interact with the
Caption: environment any interactions noise sound
Caption: thermal interactions so to make reliable
Caption: quantum computing we have to get some
Caption: sort of quantum error correction just
Caption: like we quantum we error correct some of
Caption: our ram now you can do the same thing
Caption: for quantum memory and in fact this has
Caption: already been done a guy's already
Caption: written the algorithm the good news is
Caption: the algorithm to do quantum error
Caption: correction to make sure our quantum bits
Caption: are reliable we need them to be reliable
Caption: that's the good news the bad news is
Caption: that to make one quantum bit reliable
Caption: you need about a thousand extra quantum
Caption: bits to provide redundancy and make sure
Caption: it's reliable that's quite large what
Caption: about what can these quantum computers
Caption: compute if you know about the P NP
Caption: problem
Caption: the polynomial time problems and the non
Caption: polynomial time problems we in quantum
Caption: computing we introduce a new thing
Caption: called the bounded error quantum
Caption: polynomial time calculations these are
Caption: the things you can calculate with the
Caption: quantum computer we don't know for sure
Caption: but we know at least that quantum
Caption: computer can do everything that a
Caption: classical computer can do in polynomial
Caption: time we think possibly that B Q P is
Caption: greater than P we can do things more
Caption: practically more efficiently in quantum
Caption: computers but that may just be because
Caption: we haven't found the right algorithm for
Caption: our classical computers but I tend to
Caption: think it's extra there in the quantum
Caption: computer so maybe we are greater than P
Caption: but don't think that quantum computers
Caption: are going to solve all our NP problems
Caption: there no silver bullet for that it
Caption: doesn't give us a magic solution to
Caption: solve exponential problems immediately
Caption: but it will help us solve some problems
Caption: faster so that's pretty good news maybe
Caption: your heads still uploading exploiting
Caption: but hope you're following here the idea
Caption: of a quantum computer the quantum
Caption: mechanics and using the
Caption: with quantum bits and doing processing
Caption: are you following me okay
Caption: hope so let's have a look what's the
Caption: next thing so let's look at this
Caption: physical path now the quantum computer
Caption: itself what does it look like and how
Caption: does it work as I mentioned there were
Caption: two types of quantum computers the
Caption: digital ones and the analogue ones we'll
Caption: focus on the digital ones and the way
Caption: they currently work is there's two
Caption: approaches one is called iron traps they
Caption: take an atom to get rid of some
Caption: electrons so now it's positively charged
Caption: and they use that positive charge to
Caption: trap it in electric field so they can
Caption: isolate it from everything else they can
Caption: cool it down and now they can use its
Caption: quantum states to build qubits the other
Caption: approach which is very common is
Caption: supercomputing circuits they have a
Caption: little silicon circuit but they cool it
Caption: down to nearly absolute zero and now it
Caption: becomes a superconducting circuit so now
Caption: actually shows some quantum properties
Caption: and you can use those quantum properties
Caption: to build your quantum bits the other one
Caption: uses supercomputing circuits as well
Caption: this is an example of a quantum computer
Caption: chip as you can see here it's pretty
Caption: clear these are the actual qubits you
Caption: see a little bit's there so basically I
Caption: think it's 16 qubits on this one they're
Caption: little loops where you can get
Caption: superconducting things happening when
Caption: it's cooled down to really close to
Caption: absolute zero in fact it's only it's a
Caption: couple of order of magnitudes colder
Caption: than outer space milli kelvins very very
Caption: cold but you can also see here's some
Caption: circuitry which actually produces
Caption: electric fields to allow us to interact
Caption: those with those quantum bits to perform
Caption: the operations on them to change their
Caption: quantum wave function so this is how a
Caption: new quantum computer chip looks
Caption: currently but of course that's just the
Caption: chip we have to put it inside some
Caption: infrastructure as I mentioned you need
Caption: to keep these near absolute zero so we
Caption: need to have a cryo stat with many
Caption: layers who can cool it down to get down
Caption: to this absolute zero temperature or
Caption: close to it we need to also isolate it
Caption: from any vibrations we need to also
Caption: isolate it from any electromagnetic
Caption: fields because if that quantum bit into
Caption: with the outside world radiation or
Caption: vibrations it'll become a classical
Caption: thing again and it will lose its quantum
Caption: state so we have to isolate it to keep
Caption: it
Caption: quantum so we cover this up in a
Caption: cylinder and we make it into a cryostat
Caption: here can be cooled down and now we have
Caption: a whole world of electronics to actually
Caption: control that chip to affect the chip to
Caption: make measurements to do transformations
Caption: we have a whole lot of electronics a
Caption: control processor layer to control this
Caption: stuff and then we have traditional
Caption: computers which actually program these
Caption: control systems so I think that's how
Caption: you'll see quantum computers for a
Caption: number of years going forth basically a
Caption: classical computer controlling
Caption: electronics which affect the quantum
Caption: chip so we're still using classical
Caption: computers to control this stuff now this
Caption: looks pretty old
Caption: this looks pretty bulky and air over and
Caption: I'm not very state-of-the-art sort of
Caption: thing but this is our first attempt at
Caption: quantum computers remember what our
Caption: first attempt at classical computers
Caption: look like this is Australia's first
Caption: digital computer the Cyro built so we're
Caption: at this stage currently with quantum
Caption: computers we are a long way to go but
Caption: even though we're some people these days
Caption: some companies put a shiny box around
Caption: their quantum computers and they sell
Caption: them this company d-wave sells quantum
Caption: computers which have 5000 qubits which
Caption: sounds like a lot and it is but the
Caption: problem is these qubits aren't very high
Caption: quality they decohere very quickly and
Caption: people don't believe much quantum stuff
Caption: happens they're still they can use them
Caption: for certain calculations and for
Caption: simulating quantum systems so you can
Caption: buy one from ten to fifteen million
Caption: dollars I believe IBM also build quantum
Caption: computer that you can actually buy how
Caption: do we program these things remember we
Caption: program on a classical computer to
Caption: control the electronics which control
Caption: the chip and make it do things and a
Caption: number of companies have libraries to
Caption: help you control or process this quantum
Caption: stuff Microsoft have a language called Q
Caption: sharp basically it's a DSL to help you
Caption: do quantum operations on qubits do
Caption: have a look through this car it's not
Caption: easy know how to understand here
Caption: applying a/c not operation one of those
Caption: transformations were applying it to a
Caption: particular qubit to get from here to
Caption: there let me provide a hey chopper ation
Caption: on this one and down here we're doing a
Caption: measurement of certain bits so adsl2
Caption: control the electronics to transform the
Caption: qubits inside the quantum computer and
Caption: that's how you program a quantum
Caption: computer currently it's sort of like the
Caption: machine level programming of our old
Caption: computers so there are issues of they
Caption: mentioned with quantum computing and
Caption: quantum computers there's a key
Caption: coherence problem that we lose coherence
Caption: we come out of the quantum state there's
Caption: a difficulty with input and output who
Caption: would have thought input or output would
Caption: be difficult but as it's hard to get
Caption: input into all these states to put the
Caption: quantum electrons into certain wave
Caption: states and it's hard to get the
Caption: information out because if you try and
Caption: measure the state of the quantum bits
Caption: you make them classical again so you
Caption: lose all your quantumness so you have to
Caption: do some tricky things to measure a
Caption: little bit but leave the system still
Caption: useful also I mentioned we have a short
Caption: time of decoherence so they're only last
Caption: in their quantum state for a short time
Caption: and how would you do bug one of these
Caption: systems when you can't interact with it
Caption: you can't do printf or save to a log
Caption: file
Caption: how do you do bug this sort of stuff but
Caption: the truth is here that all of this is
Caption: improving we get better at doing this
Caption: we're finding out ways how to do this to
Caption: program quantum programs in fact there
Caption: are some current records in quantum
Caption: computing the record for coherence time
Caption: keeping in that quantum state is 90
Caption: microseconds it's not very long other
Caption: systems get longer times but they're not
Caption: really quantum systems like the d-wave
Caption: ones 90 microseconds is it very long but
Caption: now we can show that we can actually
Caption: perform the operations on these qubits
Caption: very fast a team of researchers at u.s.
Caption: lwith showing they can do a qubit
Caption: operation in 0.8 nanoseconds so that
Caption: gives us quite a bit of chance to do
Caption: operations before we decohere and lose
Caption: the quantum state and the largest
Caption: digital computer currently and I know of
Caption: is seventy-two qubits
Caption: built by IBM the Bristlecone processor
Caption: and every year we get more and more so
Caption: it's basically growing every year that's
Caption: a quantum records there's a huge
Caption: investment in quantum computing explain
Caption: a bit why a bit later on but companies
Caption: like IBM Microsoft and Google have large
Caption: research labs investing millions and
Caption: millions of dollars to build quantum
Caption: computers and to understand quantum
Caption: computing
Caption: similarly there are a number of startups
Caption: like d-wave and another one called
Caption: Righetti and in fact the story is if you
Caption: go into any cafe in Silicon Valley and
Caption: start talking about quantum computing
Caption: someone will write you a check for a
Caption: million dollars straightaway everyone's
Caption: investing in quantum computing and even
Caption: the government's you know the EU is one
Caption: of the largest investors in quantum
Caption: computing research similarly for the US
Caption: and China because they see it as the
Caption: next revolution in computing it's very
Caption: significant so you maybe still have
Caption: exploding heads but now you were
Caption: enjoying it with your friends as your
Caption: head explodes it's pretty radical stuff
Caption: it's not what you'd normally think about
Caption: as computing or the way we do computing
Caption: but I want to show you in the last
Caption: section here some applications of
Caption: quantum computing you'll see why it's
Caption: really important in how it's really
Caption: important because we're in an early
Caption: stage in quantum computing and we don't
Caption: just want to copy all the things that
Caption: classical digital computers do we tend
Caption: to find that quantum computers are
Caption: problem focused not automation focused
Caption: you don't build an ERP system or a CRM
Caption: system or a banking system using quantum
Caption: computer so we can do that really well
Caption: on classical computers but there are
Caption: certain problems in classical computing
Caption: in normal computing which we have
Caption: trouble solving and quantum computers
Caption: can help us solve those let's look at
Caption: those so there are four different types
Caption: of problems that we can solve simulation
Caption: of quantum systems search factorization
Caption: and optimization I'd like to look at two
Caption: or three of these and explain them to
Caption: you to give you an idea of how it solves
Caption: these problems before we do that we
Caption: talked about the first one simulation
Caption: he's another quote from a mr. Fineman he
Caption: said that nature isn't classical dammit
Caption: that's how he spoke and if you want to
Caption: make a simulation of Nate
Caption: nature you'd better make it
Caption: quantum-mechanical and he was intrigued
Caption: by the fact that this is a jolly good
Caption: problem to try and solve it's really
Caption: hard and in the past it has been very
Caption: difficult if we wanted to simulate
Caption: electrons like electrons in a a molecule
Caption: for chemistry to see how these electrons
Caption: interact if we try and do that with a
Caption: classical system it's very very
Caption: difficult think if we had 40 electrons
Caption: in our molecule and they could be in two
Caption: quantum states but remember they're in a
Caption: soup position of all those quantum
Caption: states so you actually have two to the
Caption: forty states have to try and store in
Caption: memory it actually it comes down to
Caption: about a hundred and thirty gigabytes of
Caption: memory you'd need to store 40 electron
Caption: states in a quantum wave that would be
Caption: really tough but if you could imagine
Caption: you could get 130 gigabytes of memory
Caption: maybe we can these days if you wanted to
Caption: add one extra electron 41 it's not just
Caption: a little bit more it's two times more so
Caption: now you need 260 gigabytes of memory so
Caption: the classical resources you need to
Caption: solve quantum simulations go up
Caption: exponentially because the number of
Caption: states goes up exponentially so this is
Caption: why quantum computers are really good
Caption: for simulating quantum systems if we
Caption: have 40 bits we could simulate our 40
Caption: electrons if you want to add in one more
Caption: electron we just add in one more bit and
Caption: in fact quantum simulation using quantum
Caption: computers to model the behavior of
Caption: chemicals and so forth is basically
Caption: making the chemists really happy they
Caption: now think they've solved the problem of
Caption: simulating an understanding matter no
Caption: longer is it difficult to simulate we
Caption: can do it and understand it we can build
Caption: whatever matter we like because we
Caption: understand the chemistry and how these
Caption: applications how these are molecules and
Caption: atoms interact they think it will have
Caption: huge implications for the pharmaceutical
Caption: industry a trillion dollar industry
Caption: they're saying in using quantum
Caption: computers to simulate atoms to build
Caption: materials and the chemicals we need for
Caption: our pharmaceuticals quantum simulation
Caption: is not just a little bit
Caption: faster it's thousands of times faster
Caption: than classical computers trying to
Caption: simulate a quantum system it's
Caption: exponentially better that's huge
Caption: exponentially better so the first thing
Caption: that quantum computers do it can do is
Caption: they can simulate quantum systems in the
Caption: real world which is great the second
Caption: thing to do which we can do with quantum
Caption: computers is we can search now think
Caption: about classical search if you had in a
Caption: file with n numbers in it you wanted to
Caption: search through and find one of those
Caption: numbers it's an order of n problem
Caption: classical search on average you have to
Caption: find go through about n divided by two
Caption: before you find the one you want with a
Caption: quantum computer we can prove there's an
Caption: algorithm which is proved we can do it
Caption: in the order of square root of n and
Caption: this is quite amazing it's quadratically
Caption: better if you think about it if we were
Caption: trying to search 10 billion things to
Caption: find a needle in a haystack in the
Caption: classical computer that will require on
Caption: the order of 10 billion operations quite
Caption: a few with a quantum computer it's a
Caption: square root of that just a hundred
Caption: thousand so a lot faster to do search
Caption: once one problem area that quantum
Caption: computers can help in an example of this
Caption: is the traveling salesperson problem you
Caption: may thought about her this this is a
Caption: problem where you have a salesperson or
Caption: a tourist in this case who wants to
Caption: visit a number of different sites
Caption: he knows the distance between all of
Caption: these sites which one should they go to
Caption: in which order to see the most and
Caption: travel the least distance it's a
Caption: minimization type problem but really
Caption: it's a search problem too because you
Caption: could search through all the different
Caption: possible routes and find the one which
Caption: is the lowest and in fact this is an N
Caption: factorial problem because your first
Caption: choice is in your second choice is which
Caption: want to go to n minus 1 and you keep on
Caption: going in factorial you ever tried
Caption: factorials when your calculator by the
Caption: time you get to 110 you blow up your
Caption: calculator because factorials get very
Caption: large very quickly but the nice thing is
Caption: quantum can do this search in the order
Caption: of square root of n so even though it's
Caption: huge it can do it quite quickly it can
Caption: solve this problem
Caption: and the way we do this is some guy named
Caption: Grover suggested that Grover's algorithm
Caption: how to do this and basically here is
Caption: that diagram again showing you our
Caption: quantum states or applying operations
Caption: but these are like modules or functions
Caption: with a whole lot of operations inside so
Caption: we do this particular step then we find
Caption: a short route yes or no we do this step
Caption: and check for the short route and he
Caption: described this operations and these
Caption: things you do in detail some of them are
Caption: quite complex some of them are like
Caption: quite classical to calculate the square
Caption: root the shortest route that will the
Caption: length of the route you have to do some
Caption: classical operations but remember
Caption: quantum computers can do classical
Caption: operations so we have a whole lot of
Caption: them there and at the thing is once you
Caption: follow this algorithm it can actually
Caption: solve this problem in order of square
Caption: root end time so in the past traveling
Caption: salesperson when it got large was too
Caption: hard now we can do a lot more
Caption: calculations and using the quantum
Caption: system so how does this actually work
Caption: this quantum approach it's hard to
Caption: explain
Caption: remember these operations are operating
Caption: on the qubits and changing their state
Caption: in the quantum space that's what they're
Caption: doing but it's hard to give an allergy
Caption: to this so the thing I best thing I saw
Caption: was this one if we lived in northern
Caption: Africa and wanted to get to the Iberian
Caption: Peninsula just across the water here if
Caption: we didn't have a boat we had to do
Caption: classical search we'd go all the way
Caption: around through Europe take a long time
Caption: to get there but quantum computing gives
Caption: us a new way to travel it's like the
Caption: boat we can just go across quickly
Caption: across this distance and be there in a
Caption: short amount of time it doesn't solve
Caption: the problem completely if this long
Caption: distance is still huge we're in trouble
Caption: but it's a lot better than taking the
Caption: land approach the boat solution the
Caption: quantum solution is much better quantum
Caption: TSB ok so we saw that one yeah okay so
Caption: the second example as far as number
Caption: three there is quantum cryptography the
Caption: idea here is can we use quantum systems
Caption: to build cryptographic systems or to
Caption: crack our current cryptographic systems
Caption: and we have some bad news and some good
Caption: news the bad news is in 1994
Caption: Shaw wrote an algorithm for factoring
Caption: integers large inches integers and it
Caption: used something called a quantum fast
Caption: Fourier transform it basically looks for
Caption: periods of repetition in numbers and he
Caption: said oops he said that you could use
Caption: this algorithm to factor a large integer
Caption: and you could do it in polynomial log of
Caption: the end time which is a lot less than we
Caption: currently can do it so it's basically
Caption: almost exponentially faster than the
Caption: market most efficiently non classical
Caption: algorithms so the bad news here is if we
Caption: have a quantum computer that can do this
Caption: it can break all our current encryptions
Caption: which use large prime factors of
Caption: integers that's the bad news the good
Caption: news is this was developed in 1994 and
Caption: we haven't really developed a quantum
Caption: computer that can do it at the moment
Caption: and probably not in the next ten years
Caption: we'll be able to do it but in 10 years
Caption: time probably we'll be able to break a
Caption: current encryption this is a diagram
Caption: showing you how Shor's algorithm would
Caption: work some of the classical operations
Caption: some of the quantum operations you'd do
Caption: it's a prescribed set of operations on
Caption: these bits and it gives you out the
Caption: period or the repetition or the integers
Caption: factors of this large integer now no
Caption: one's implemented it yet but its
Caption: potential there once we get a computer
Caption: to actually do this stuff so there's a
Caption: warning here
Caption: quantum factorization is coming it
Caption: breaks
Caption: public key cryptography now as I
Caption: mentioned it may not happen next year it
Caption: may take ten years but imagine if we had
Caption: to change all of our cryptography
Caption: because when this stuff happens
Caption: people who get these sort of computers
Caption: will be able to break into all
Caption: information that's currently stored in a
Caption: symmetric key encryption anything that's
Caption: encrypted it'll also be able to break
Caption: into all communication that is currently
Caption: encrypted HTTP communication SSL stuff
Caption: all now break into it so some Russians
Caption: or Chinese break this stuff will
Caption: actually be open to them eavesdropping
Caption: so this is why the big government and
Caption: the military in the u.s. are putting a
Caption: effort into finding the next
Caption: cryptography to replace replace a
Caption: current approach something like a
Caption: quantum cryptography perhaps so that
Caption: there if I can find a solution will take
Caption: seven years or so to roll out
Caption: exclusively and change all our
Caption: encryption will be ready when the
Caption: quantum computers come along and
Caption: actually break our encryption so
Caption: something to worry about something to
Caption: think about there the quantum solution
Caption: for encryption uses that idea of
Caption: entanglement if we can take an electron
Caption: here or a number of electrons and split
Caption: it apart and give it to somebody else
Caption: then they can look at the electrons and
Caption: see what our electrons like and that's
Caption: like sharing a public key and we can do
Caption: that privately and instantaneously so we
Caption: can use the entanglement approach of
Caption: quantum systems to make quantum
Caption: cryptography but there's no time to go
Caption: in there so last thing I want to talk
Caption: about just quickly is machine learning
Caption: in AI it's actually the machine learning
Caption: in AI involves a lot of systems of
Caption: linear equations multiplying matrices
Caption: and multiplying matrices and quantum kun
Caption: is actually quite good at doing this
Caption: very good at doing this you make up a
Caption: whole of quantum state and you can
Caption: process them like you would matrices but
Caption: the problem with quantum computers is
Caption: you can't really get the information out
Caption: easily you cannot find is what is the
Caption: solution to this quantum matrix
Caption: multiplication but what you can find is
Caption: properties of the solution now is it
Caption: this or is it that type of solution
Caption: general properties holistic properties
Caption: and people have actually written
Caption: recommendation engines algorithms using
Caption: quantum operations that can perform
Caption: recommendations like a Netflix does and
Caption: the way the traditional systems do it is
Caption: they look at all the movies you've
Caption: watched and try to recommend one based
Caption: on those they're found with a quantum
Caption: system just by looking at a log number
Caption: of queries a log number of your movies
Caption: so a much smaller number you can make a
Caption: good recommendation so in the future we
Caption: may use quantum systems to do
Caption: recommendation engines but also help
Caption: with general AI algorithms to speed them
Caption: up to make them a lot faster so there
Caption: you go that's what I'm talking about for
Caption: quantum computers today I hope that
Caption: hasn't really blown your mind maybe it's
Caption: expanded your mind maybe you've learned
Caption: something or got a glimpse of what
Caption: quantum computing is like as I said it's
Caption: a quite sick
Caption: difficut to wind up here I shall make a
Caption: summary the first thing is hopefully
Caption: you've seen that quantum computing is a
Caption: really new type of computing based on
Caption: quantum physics not classical physics
Caption: hopefully you seen that quantum
Caption: computers are built around operations on
Caption: a number of quantum bits smallish number
Caption: we probably need to get to thousands
Caption: before we can do things really well but
Caption: not necessarily millions and quantum
Caption: computers seem to be able to solve some
Caption: problems much faster than classical
Caption: computers did but they don't solve all
Caption: problems they're not the magical
Caption: solution to everything
Caption: there are a number of resources you
Caption: might want to have a look to he if you
Caption: want to learn more about quantum
Caption: computing you want to learn more about
Caption: the theory there's a great paper or
Caption: article or book written by the National
Caption: Academy of Science in the u.s. all about
Caption: quantum computing the process the
Caption: progress and the prospects for the
Caption: future and also a major computer
Caption: companies like Microsoft IBM and Google
Caption: have libraries where you can actually go
Caption: and start to play around and code and
Caption: that code may actually interact with the
Caption: system which is a simulation of a
Caption: quantum computer so you're ready when
Caption: quantum computers come on but some of
Caption: them actually have small-scale quantum
Caption: computers say five cubits week as you
Caption: run your program on a real quantum
Caption: computer for free and try things out but
Caption: there's no large-scale quantum computers
Caption: available at this time so what are our
Caption: milestones and where we at with quantum
Caption: computing when we finished this shows
Caption: you a number of different milestones we
Caption: can go through with quantum keys to get
Caption: to their final endgame this side here is
Caption: the analog computers simulating systems
Caption: there's not too far to go with this one
Caption: here a long way to go the first stage is
Caption: probably react we've got small systems
Caption: of tens of qubits we haven't gone that
Caption: far the first real major milestone with
Caption: quantum computing is when we make some
Caption: digital quantum computer that does
Caption: something that's not really practical
Caption: ever in a classical computer and that's
Caption: what we call quantum supremacy sorry
Caption: quantum computers can do something that
Caption: a classical computer can't do or at
Caption: least the algorithms we know currently
Caption: that's the next step but there are a lot
Caption: of steps to go through there
Caption: so I've had to think about the future I
Caption: haven't got a crystal ball so I can't
Caption: see the future they've had to think
Caption: about it what would I say well let's say
Caption: that quantum supremacy
Caption: that's when quantum computers are better
Caption: is coming probably in the next few years
Caption: so look at in the press in the
Caption: technology press if you hear talk of
Caption: quantum supremacy is achieved you know
Caption: things are really heating up fast
Caption: getting important but what about the
Caption: future the distance well there's one
Caption: thing about humans here and technology
Caption: that I know is true and will we explain
Caption: this what the future is going to be like
Caption: if you think about the future humans
Caption: tend to predict the future linearly we
Caption: see the past and put a nice linear line
Caption: to the future and so things don't change
Caption: very much when you look linearly humans
Caption: predict linearly but technology it
Caption: improves exponentially so we're thinking
Caption: that the computers are going to just be
Caption: like this I'll take 20 or 30 years but
Caption: does this so one thing I can say for
Caption: sure is quantum computer is going to
Caption: happen sooner than you expect them to
Caption: because you're predicting linearly
Caption: they're gonna happen a lot faster just
Caption: like the internet did and voice
Caption: recognition data and all this stuff it
Caption: came one minute we haven't got it they
Caption: spent we've all got it and it's just
Caption: natural stuff quantum computing will be
Caption: here soon so whether you get a i phone
Caption: QC or not I'm not sure there's no reason
Caption: why we can't have room-temperature
Caption: superconducting stuff and we can feel it
Caption: inside a device like this
Caption: so I'm not gonna say never know people
Caption: who say never always prove wrong but
Caption: possibly so that's the end of my talk
Caption: and we've talked about exploiting heads
Caption: and here's one head I would like to
Caption: explode but maybe not but even if your
Caption: head did explode today hopefully you saw
Caption: some beauty along the way and it was an
Caption: interesting and you saw an elegant
Caption: glimpse into what quantum computing and
Caption: quantum computers and programming of
Caption: quantum systems and the solutions I can
Caption: solve will be like thank you very much
Caption: but I think we have time for questions
Caption: but that's all thank you